it's the just white shirt the white
t-shirt has been a wardrobe and
pop-culture staple for decades I totally
get why the white t-shirt has withstood
the test of time
it's a classic versatile basic that goes
with virtually anything I was really
surprised to find out that white
t-shirts were actually originally issued
by the US Navy in the early 1900s and
were considered underwear so I had the
idea for three of my friends and I to
try and style the same plain white
t-shirt just to show how easily you can
integrate it into your own personal
style we're gonna go to my closet now so
here's it's nice super fitted kind of
like cinches in my waist
although I want you to do something jazz
it up cuz right now and this is kind of
like my high school band outfit you know
when you have your concert and you have
to wear own weight top and a black
bottom like I think everyone's gonna
look super cute and they're gonna have
put together like really nice looks and
then it just made me like looking like a
potato so this is just what I'm gonna
wear for the work so I have my white
t-shirt I'm ready to go I think I want
to pair it with Russ but I'm not
entirely sure I think I might just wear
underneath one of these three dresses
depending on my favorites so I'm gonna
try to I was trying to do this thing
where I like talking to it and then I
wear like a necklace but I don't know if
this is my favorite look but I wanted to
try a couple of jeans wait I think I had
this one perfect pair of jeans I have a
few options that I'm excited about so
let's see those so with the dresses
obviously I would just wear the dresses
with the light t-shirt underneath and
then with those two shirts I would wear
the white t-shirt underneath and then I
would wear jeans my only worry is that
it's gonna be hot tomorrow so I'm kind
of thinking of going with one of the
dresses so I've been wanting to wear
this one but I didn't feel like it was
super work appropriate so I feel like
putting the white t-shirt under it could
make it a lot more appropriate so
there's my dogs here's the dress the top
and then I just added this little like
Lock necklace which i think is pretty
cute yeah I think I'll just add some
socks to go with my dogs and I think
that it's super cute I really like the
style in the 80s and like 90s movies so
maybe I can play that up using the white
tee I think what I'm gonna do is layer
my white t-shirt under this little denim
dress that I found in my closet I
actually don't think I've ever worn this
before and scrunchy yes let's go blue
there we go
I really like that do you like it you
just look sad
so I'm really into mom jeans but I never
really could find anything to wear with
them until the basic white tee after
wearing it this morning I realized to
open up so many more options in the
closet and I chose specifically the mom
jeans because it's so comfortable very
casual and then it added this headband
here because it makes to look like Rosie
the Riveter
I just tried to incorporate the basic
white t-shirt into what I would normally
wear so I added it with a skirt and I
tucked it in added a nice little lace
kimono type thing to keep everything
flowing
[Music]
[Music]
I mix it up with my checkerboard bands
and this pattern scrunchie because I
kind of like clashing different patterns
together and then added the little
overall bib dress just you know good
cute
I went from looking like a little boy to
looking like a kindergarten teacher but
I like that I think it's a good vibe for
me I have been styling my white t-shirts
like this for a few months now I'm
obsessed with it I put a white t-shirt
under a tank top I put it literally
under anything of course dresses I feel
like it just makes a dress more work
appropriate which I really like I think
that our little experiment just shows
all the different ways you can utilize a
white t-shirt which is the whole point
of this video when you think of a white
t-shirt you think of like casual and
comfortable but me here prove that you
can actually dress it up and make it so
fit your style and it's really awesome
to see what we all came up with after
just like one day of like thinking what
yeah basic white team apparently is
faithful I'm gonna keep it
you